hi my name is Maria Valeri and I play
Maria hi I'm Benjamin wodsworth and I
play Marcos
[Music]
[Applause]
my fiancee I call him right away I was
in Venezuela and I called him screaming
and crying and just over the moon my
best friend he was I was I was at we
were we were at our brothers soccer
toward a championship and we I told him
[Music]
man same math I was really bad at it
dyslexia and math just aren't a great
mix I guess and I guess I have other
talents just not with the numbers I do
things seems to be working
yeah I hope so
[Music]
we I just I just I just read the comic
as many times as I could you know just
to get Marcus's physicality in the way
he thought why he thinks the way he
thinks if I had any other specific
questions I could just go to Rick Rick
was very informative and Marcus and I
are pretty similar to an extent so it
was it was a bit easier for me I'd say
for me it was definitely a lot of work
at first um I need a to hire a personal
trainer to you know get very strong and
be able to do all these action scenes
and then dig deep into my anxieties and
fears and insecurities because Maria is
bipolar and she medicated secretly and
also she's not that great at medicating
herself so she goes on and off meds and
that's quite a trip for her and and and
I got to experience that definitely in
one scene there's a lot going on with
Maria that I needed to be able to do in
like very fast
oh man I wish I wish we could just get
these characters out of our minds for
when we go home yeah yeah you need like
a good amount of time to decompress
these characters are so are so dark and
flawed and and they're just trying to
make it through I mean it does stick
with you yeah and you know what
absolutely at some point your body
doesn't really know the difference
between the reality and fiction and so
and you also take stuff from your real
life to play this character so you
really have to take a moment after the
days wrap to kind of breathe and you
know listen to happy music and think
about something else because it does
think I told you I would say
episode 5 episode 5 is a winner
it's trip it allows some of us to be as
maniacal as we one that's very fun thing
to have as an actor
we didn't really have he was the one he
would always go and do like this and I
will turn around and he would be like
you and then we're not gonna use to it
he would do this
yeah and I would stay on the same day on
the same side on the same side so I
would never win
it would drive me crazy no in real life
I'm I'm drying and melancholy but on set
and working every day with the same
people it really just makes you want to
mess around they said no they said I
remember we're on the pilot Lana was
like asking everyone questions and she
looks at me and just stares just like
are you dead inside I was like no just
on the outside
[Music]
I lost a bit of weight a lot of nervous
crying yeah and a really big deep into
her insecurities and fears and anxieties
and you know hope for the best
yeah absolutely I mean I after the pilot
I gained some weight I started working
out for the first time with weights but
then Rick told Rick Remender told me to
stop and his Marcus is a homeless kid so
I took it the opposite extreme and
stopped eating I started eating one meal
a day and started running and then I
lost like seven pounds in the Rick was
like Jesus and tell you this up eating
eat a sandwich or something so no I just
don't do anything so yeah I don't really
so it was just my answers basically no I
don't do anything yeah a lot of working
out and push-ups and pull-ups and abs
and squats and all of that
yeah
I think teleclass perfectly captures the
essence of teenage angst in 1987 in the
the punk scene it's it's action-packed
it's full of character and and drama
it's an unlikely coming-of-age story
full of teen angst and great music and
it's a heightened world and it tackles
familiar seems like love betrayal and
revenge and and and you'll get to feel
related to all these characters and and
really live your teenage years but in a
really fun way because it happens in an
academy for assassin catch deadly class
on Syfy January 16th 10 p.m. 8:00
central on Wednesdays